ومن بين من شملتهم ارقام الضحايا الناشطه
العربيه الاهوازيه عاطفه نعامي التي عثر
على جثتها في شقتها السبت الماضي
ووجدت جثه هذه الشابه مغطاه ببطانيه في
شرفه منزلها وبجانبها خرطوم متصل بصمام
غازي بالقرب من فمها السلطات الايرانيه
دفنتها الاثنين على عجل بمقبره في مدينه
كرج مع حضور عدد قليل من النساء من افراد
الاسره
تقرير طبي مفصل عن سبب الوفاه الا ان
شقيقها قال من منفاه لموقع ايران واير ان
انتحار قال ان انتحار شقيقته سيناريو
ملافق وانها لم تكن تفكر في الانتحار خاصه
بعدما التحقت بالحراكس نساوي في ايران
اتهموا السلطات في اكثر من مره باختلاقي
انباء انتحار نشاطات او المحتاجين لتنفي
عن نفسها مسؤوليه قتل المحتاجين
والمتظاهرين كما انها تجبر اهالي القتل
على الاعتراف بان اقاربهم انتحروا او
سقطوا من مكان عال
فات المنزلي مثلا وفي تفاصيل العثور على
جثه عاطفه بواسطه اسرتها قال شقيقها ان
الشرطه وخلافا لما هو متبع تخلصت من بعض
الادله في مسرح الجريمه كما ان احد الضباط
الحاضرين لمكان الحادث قال للاسره ان
الوفاه ليست ناجمه عن انتحار وفقا
لملاحظاته